this weekend my wife left me because i
kept saying i'm a transformer
she didn't believe me but trust me i can
change
and we're already off to a bad start but
transformers warfare cybertron
is now out on netflix and yeah there's a
lot to talk about
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the new show
it's ending and where things could be
going in the future obviously there's
gonna be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
full series yet
then you better transform this video
into a non-spoiler review
very very fast if you enjoy the video
then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for content like this every day
with all out the way welcome to the
heavy spoiler show
now let's get into our breakdown of
transformers warfare cybertron
okay so siege is the first in the war
for cybertron trilogy
which is set to be debuting on netflix
over the next couple of years
it's a sort of reimagining of the war
between the autobots and decepticons
and will predominantly be retelling the
origins story with a couple of updates
and additions
the show sets the scenes with the
decepticons ruling over cybertron
and possessing complete control of the
planet as always
their leader is megatron and he wishes
to crush the autobahn uprising
before they can take back power imagine
just imagine the opening scene of
bumblebee
but for an entire series and you pretty
much have the outline of the show
if you're like me then you'd think that
that was the best part of
not only that movie but any transformers
movie ever
and it's great to see us getting a full
rendition of it here in animated form
now as with most rebel uprising
entertainment
every story needs its macguffin whether
it's the plans for the death star
the power stone or the one ring to rule
them all
when the forces of good are facing down
against an almost unbeatable empire
they need something to make the job
easier for the autobots it is of course
the all spark
the infamous ancient artifact that has
the ability to bring machines to life
the old spark was actually responsible
for the creation of all life on
cybertron
and if you caught with transformers law
then i'm sure you'll be well aware of it
little is known about its origins but we
do know that it kick-started the first
dynasty of primes
and those that served them the show's
centers around the decepticons in
autobots wrestling for control over it
whilst
several subplots take place there's
really four campaigns going on at the
same time
and these all sort of connect for the
one overarching goal of getting off
world with the all spark
on the other side of the coin is the
decepticons who wish to take the old
spark
and using its abilities unleash a
powerful wave of programming
that will reformat all of the autobots
that's pretty much the plot of siege
and though it's getting mixed reviews
online i definitely think that there's a
lot to enjoy here in terms of the story
i don't think it quite lives up to the
original work however
if you're a transformers fan and let's
face it who isn't
you'll definitely find it a blast the
show is absolutely gorgeous looking
and considering this is animated there
were a lot of times that i thought
everything looked photorealistic
the autobots have to retrieve the old
spark repair the space bridge
and also collect enough energon to give
power to the ark which will transport
them away
optimus and kogo after the main item
ratchet the space bridge
and bumble bee the energon bumblebee
actually gets a lot to do this season
and in the beginning he's a sort of
scavenger only interested in surviving
day to day
he's not really into the idea of
fighting but as the season goes on he
becomes more and more indebted to the
cause
and of course turns into the more
classic version that we've come to know
and love
this ideology is reflected through
several of the autobots themselves
and many are interested in purely
avoiding extinction for as long as they
can
but optimus sees that in the long run
they're merely delaying the inevitable
rather than ending it thus they must
fight in order to reach the day
they no longer have to fight there's
obviously some dissenters amongst the
autobot ranks
and ultra magnus goes to megatron with
the hopes of striking up a peace treaty
in order to avoid any more oil shed
it's here that he learns of their plans
to gain the oil spark and he sends a
warning out to his allies
using a stockpile of highly concentrated
energy on they lay a trap for the group
and attack when the autobots try to
retrieve it megatron executes ultra
magnus after he leads them on a wild
goose chase
and using propaganda he publicly ends
the truce between the autobots and the
decepticons
he also orders shockwave to unleash an
anti-autobot virus
and this severely depletes the autobot
numbers there are several members of the
decepticon forces such as jetfire that
disagree with how dishonorable this is
and the show tackles complicated themes
like patriotism
and following certain beliefs impactor
is a key example
that shows being patriotic doesn't also
mean blindly following the government in
orders
especially if you know them to be wrong
i love how some question
what it actually means to win and if you
betray your principles and beliefs
does that mean you betray what you were
fighting for in the first place
the show doesn't necessarily give a
right or wrong answer
and it adds a lot of subtext to the
series now it's revealed later in the
series
that bumblebee had the alpha trion
protocols uploaded to his brain from
ultra magnus the instant the character
was killed
this massively changes his perspective
and the wealth of knowledge he gains
alters how he views the war
and life itself this is mirrored in the
guardians
who optimus goes to seeking aid similar
to bumblebee they initially refuse to
get involved in the conflict
even though they know it will have
severe repercussions to the planet
though it seems like the pleas fall on
deaf ears omega supreme
does eventually join the fight showing
that in action
is not always the right option after all
evil triumphs when good men
i mean machines fail to act and i really
appreciated that the show was laced with
an ocean that
though it's easier sometimes to keep out
of trouble it isn't always the right
thing to do
with the alpha trion protocols the
autobots gain the location of the all
spock
bumble bee fully joins their forces and
this takes us towards the final act of
the series
optimus and his group travel into the
hazardous rust lands to retrieve the
allspark
and shockwave uploads the virus to ultra
magnus in order to destroy the alpha
trion code no matter where it may be
to make matters worse the virus greatly
affects the autobot numbers
and the alpha trion code is wiped from
bumblebee's head
against all odds the group succeeds and
they manage to retrieve the old spark
energy on and repair the space bridge
optimus rides there with the oil spark
whilst elite one and her forces try to
create a distraction for the decepticons
unfortunately megatron realizes that
optimus is heading to the space bridge
with your spark
and the two-faced down there now it's a
brilliant battle
and i absolutely loved seeing the two
face off against one another
they don't get much screen time against
each other in the series but
you know these little moments they're
few and far between and you really got
to appreciate them
megatron sees optimus as a traitor for
wishing to destroy the planet that they
live on
and juxtaposing this optimus ceases
tyranny as something that has instead
led to its downfall
it really makes you feel like cybertron
is lost and optimus himself
almost loses the fight against the
villain luckily bumblebee stops megatron
from taking the old spark
and in this moment optimus launches it
into the space bridge
sending it to parts unknown impactor
sacrifices himself
and alita one launches the arc heading
towards the space bridge
to provide a vessel for the autobots to
escape the planet
just as it seems the decepticons are
closing in a mega supreme arrives
and fights on the side of the autobots
for the good of cybertron
seeing the gigantic titan take them down
is excellent and i love watching
the massive massive machine decimate the
decepticons
it buys the autobots time to flee the
ark but just as they're about to escape
elite one decides to stay behind you get
the feeling that she and optimus were
really
close but due to the duty that she feels
towards protecting the planet against
megatron's forces
she decides to remain in fight possibly
dividing the decepticons attention
which will of course give the autobots
more of a chance to get away
as they arrive at the space bridge it
seems to explode
potentially killing all of the autobots
on board this leaves illitera one
wondering whether her friends made her
out or not
but she vows to continue the fight in
honor of them
jet fire arrives to beef up the numbers
and you really get the feeling that
even if their allies are potentially
gone they won't stop
fighting but what of the fate of the ark
i try to sound epic there but it it
failed a bit
now i don't think that you need to be
alpha tryon to know that the arc
actually made it off the planet and
after the series comes to a close
we're treated to a cool little
post-credit teaser in which we see the
lights of teletran 1 power up
this cements that the autobots did
indeed escape cybertron
and that they survived the trip through
the space bridge teletran one is of
course the sentient computer system that
runs the autobot arc
and thus it activating showcases
everything on board is okay
now there's primarily two theories
surrounding this and the first one is
that the autobots made it to earth
and the military or some other agencies
are coming to investigate what crash
landed on the planet
the second is that they're in space and
have encountered other life forms
we can confirm though that it is indeed
the latter due to what we see just
before teletran one powers up
you have to really turn your tv
brightness up to see it and if you're
running netflix with 4k
dolby vision then you probably missed it
but
just before the computer activates we
can indeed see the arc flowing in the
vast emptiness of space
so they are okay and have indeed come
across someone
now who this is is up in the air but it
is likely the quintessons
due to the fact that well a new toy line
has been launched for the series
the quintessons are actually an ancient
race that are known as galaxy-wide
traders and businessmen
they possess advanced technology and
travel the universe are looking for life
forms to deal with
thus it does make sense that an unknown
vessel in space
coming across the ark would be
interested in getting closer to it
i actually think that the arc may be
very low on power and thus they'll trade
with them in order to find a way to
repair the
ship and continue their journey to the
ul spark now as for the old spark
though we don't know for definite
exactly where it is the fact that the
next part of the trilogy is called earth
rise
it does kind of give it away i think
that next time optimus
will take his forces to earth and this
will hammer home megatron's comments on
how the autobots were happy to devastate
other planets with their war
let's face it they have to make it to
earth at some point in order to tie in
more with the transformers legacy that's
come before and
with a title like earthrise it does make
a lot of sense
on top of this another big question that
hangs over the show is
what happened to omega supreme well
personally i think that the character
actually perished in the explosion that
we saw at the bridge
i know that's an unpopular opinion and
i've seen a number of theories saying
that
he may have went with the autobots but
i'm not exactly sure if this is the case
personally i think that his death will
snap the guardians out of their apathy
and they'll realize that this war will
eventually reach them if they don't act
quickly
this will force them to choose a side
and it will definitely elevate the
series in several ways
megatron will of course be worried that
the guardians may actually join the
battle
and thus i think you will either try and
win them over or exterminate them
completely
i feel like next time we will see the
war continue on cybertron
whilst optimus and his forces try to
obtain the old spark on earth
i think megatron will send key
decepticons to get them
and we will see as the war plays out
across the universe with the guardians
becoming involved too
i also think that though the alpha
triumph protocols
may be gone from bumblebee's head that
there will be a way to retrieve them
and this will provide the autobots with
information on what to do next
some of the autobots also getting left
behind on cybertron
is a really interesting aspect and hey
i'm very hyped for what comes next
now before we get into the rest of the
video i just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the mcu
infinity sugar box set to one random
subscriber
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video subscribe
to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the series in
the comments section below the winner is
going to be chosen at random on the 15th
of august and the cell be shipped out
from then to ever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
okay so what did i think of the series
as a whole well
whilst this is getting cold too dark and
too short
i actually disagree i i think when the
trilogy is fully available
and we have the entire arc excuse the
pun things will make a lot more sense
and there'll be a lot more dynamism to
the piece for our first chapter
i think this is the perfect length and
it brilliantly puts the pieces in place
for a lot of potential
avenues in the future sure it wasn't
perfect
but i think when the dust settles on the
entire trilogy this will be a lot better
as a port warner
overall i had fun with war for cybertron
and this is an easy binge
that gets a 7.5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show and what you took
from the ending
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then make sure you
check out our theories on the umbrella
academy which is going to be linked at
the end if you want to support the
channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter anyway
thanks for making it until the end of
the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
you